the other piece of Congressional
hearings today
involves a little bit of a prediction
that took place a few months ago by many
of the people who do what I do
and that is as soon as Marjorie Taylor
green gets on a committee it's going to
be chaos
and she's going to not earnestly take
the work seriously
she's going to be someone who's there to
create clips for Newsmax and Fox News
and oan
and she started off with the bang
I will say this though it's very clear
that she's well she's obviously a dumb
dumb but she's out of practice having
not served on committees for so long
uh in her previous term
and
let me just set the stage for you she's
she's questioning Gene Daddario who's
the the Comptroller general of these
United States and uh and the head of the
the U.S government accountability office
and Marjorie Taylor Green's asking all
these just whacked questions about
whether or not covid dollars relief
money went to support or went to fund
CRT and then other things but let's
start with the the just the jackassery
of the concept of this question here's
Marjorie Taylor green fighting the good
fight adarro can you tell me uh how much
how much coveted cash went to CRT
it's CRT critical race Theory and
education it's it's a racist uh uh
curriculum used to teach children uh
that somehow their white skin is not
equal to black skin and other things in
education yeah uh no I do not know that
but I I do know that there's Provisions
that the federal funds generally are not
used they're supposed to be used for
curriculum oh that's a statement oh Mr
Daddario I have to tell you in Illinois
that they receive 5.1 billion
um at an elementary school there that
that used it for equity and diversity
um so it's it's being used for these
things uh Mr De Niro can you
foreign
I mean of all the summations that you
could hear uh that try to Define what
CRT critical race theory is that's one I
haven't heard that they teach that black
skin is somehow or white skin is not as
good as black skin
and then the claim that an elementary
school a single Elementary School in
Illinois received
5.1 billion dollars in covid relief to
teach CRT
that's one hell of a covid uh curriculum
if if you're asking me uh 5.1 billion
would fund hundreds of schools not just
a single Elementary School's curriculum
in this specific thing that they're
trying to fear-monger
critical race Theory one isn't being
taught in elementary schools
because it is a graduate level uh
critical theory
it is for law students it is not for
elementary kids and it's most certainly
not that black skin is better than white
skin or white skin isn't as good
as black skin or or uh yeah as as blacks
see it's this is so stupid it's even
difficult for I mean I am a bit of a
dum-dum myself but this is so stupid and
it's even difficult for me to even
recite
so the questioning went on she's very
concerned about covid dollars and where
they went where relief money was spent
uh she she also is asking the same man
who's a very serious dude has a very
serious job about the funding with covid
dollars of drag queen Story Hour dinero
can you tell me how much money was given
to drag queens Story Hour
that I'm sorry could you repeat that
drag queen Story Time where where men
dress up as women and read confusing
books to Children yeah first I thought
you said dry clean so I'm sorry uh no I
don't know the answer to either one of
those two oh we need to look into this
and I urge you to do that um they uh
Bradberry Sullivan LGBT community center
in Pennsylvania received sixteen
thousand dollars uh for drag queen story
time uh from from coveted cash
um I think this is an issue that needs
to be looked into a lot of this money
went to things that should have never
gone to and I thank you so much and I
yield back the remainder of my time if
only she would permanently yield back
the remainder of her time I think
America would be better off
look if an lgbtq Community Center
received covid funds it's not
specifically earmarked for drag queen
Story Hour
which by the way no one is being harmed
by that where they're re they read
confusing books she says
look bring it in Marge bring it in just
because you're confused by a book
doesn't mean that book is inherently
confusing
she continued it's not just CRT the
dangers of CRT and it's not just
drag queen Story Hour it's also
talking about her own PPP loan she
wanted to get it on the record in case
it got brought up by someone else that's
all I can assume but she's denigrating
someone for taking PPP money while
admitting that she also took PPP money
it make it make sense watch this hey Mr
chairman I'd like to bring up something
that was brought up by one of our
Democrat colleagues on this panel about
Republican members of Congress taking
PPP loans I I never took one as a member
of Congress but as a business owner I
did take a PPP Loan in order to be able
to pay my employees and I'm so thankful
I was able to do that because they would
have lost their jobs and I think it's
important to recognize but the minority
side of our our committee here is having
a witness on the next panel that had
said that she didn't or or her or any of
her Affiliates take any federal grants
or contract tracks related to this
hearing's subject matter but in fact as
executive director of the national
employment law project they took it they
took over 825
000 in PPP loans from the SBA so that
that does need to be pointed out about
the next panel Witnesses uh here we are
a nation
and in her mind she just leveled a
devastating blow
oh
remember this tweet from like August
where the White House put up uh all of
the different Congress people who were
maligning the Forgiveness of student
loans who took hundreds of thousands and
sometimes millions of dollars in PPP
loans
yeah this is congresswoman Marjorie
Taylor green had a hundred and eighty
three thousand five hundred four dollars
in PPP loans forgiven
so it is the height of hypocrisy it is
the height of stupidity and it is
um an aggrieved Republican who's looking
to take out their frustrations and
Vengeance on
uh Democrats I guess but through the
American people and also by not doing
their job this they talk about fraud
waste and abuse so much it's a common
refrain but really the fraud waste and
abuse here in this case on this segment
is Marjorie Taylor green not doing her
job yet still getting paid to do it
you know I have a very acute Newfound
appreciation for how busy being a new
parent makes you if you have a little
one at home like me here's something
really easy you can do to simplify your
life our sponsor little spoon is your
One-Stop shop for healthy easy meal time
and snack time for your baby toddler or
big kid delivered right to your door
little spoon delivers fresh organic baby
food which comes in single ingredient
varieties or multi-textured purees
little spoon is meals for toddlers and
big kids they're free of junk and taste
great even the pickiest eaters love them
I've even tried many of them myself they
really are great having healthy snack
time is so easy with little spoons
organic smoothies which come in
convenient pouches in great flavors like
strawberry banana shake purple carrot
acai I love purple carrots I'm gonna
admit that my girlfriend and I have had
a great experience with our little spoon
subscription it just makes life easier
anything to reduce the chaos is a great
thing little spoon is giving my audience
50 off your first order go to
littlespoon.com and use code Pacman 50
off all one word the info is down below